[Music]
monitoring as the term says you're
monitoring you're watching your logging
your production environment of course
there are whole bunch of monitoring
tools so they become an important part
of your production environment and that
is these monitoring tools are also
unclean the motion being used the senior
UAP environment and you can optionally
have them for some time even in your
development environment no not
development duty development servers are
usually not very high-end configurations
but you know maybe a decent development
slash integration server especially if
you have long running scripts and if you
have programs that use a lot of servers
you know maybe CPU or a processing power
so then you can have monitoring tools
when you're writing such scripts and you
know you're doing the unit testing for
those grips so that you know to see what
kind of server utilization happens when
you run this script you know if you will
put this in production will it actually
in a slow down your production server
and what kind of impact that you have on
the you know your rest of your
application or other applications
running on that server but this
particular chapter is more in context
with production environment so these
tools to basically monitor your server
they bind to your switches post events
or your application than any services
that you have deployed on your server
and they generate alerts when something
goes wrong and that's the whole job of
monitoring it is continuously watching
continuously looking at what is running
what is happening what is going up what
is going down when it is the CPU peaking
when is memory peaking and all the
so that you can you typically send
limits for these all these different
parameters and anytime any of these
parameters goes outside of that limit
you know even more than that or less
than that these monitoring tools usually
send out an alert and these alerts could
again the SMS alert email alerts and
there are usually people monitoring
these monitoring tools or to look look
out for any issues reported and they
also generate alerts when the problem
has been resolved so it was both fail
scenarios is an open source monitoring
tool and it can even monitor your
network services it's a little diagram
here it's so small but here is snazzier
somewhere what I can read and stated to
be the different devices I think no no
no we are these are different devices to
which Maggio's is the standings and
skaters there's a browser there's an
estimate is an email and then there is a
graph also and these are different
objects that Nigel is basically
monitoring this is an SMTP server I can
read differently
tcp/ip no I don't know some database
server
okay this is a database server and this
is an application server do you switch
routers okay okay I can read that now so
this is a different kind of object is a
different kind of server that Maggio's
monitor and these are the different kind
of devices or statuses that it can send
so it helps monitor your CPU usage
you're just usage and you know even your
system long and if you use the plug-in
script that can be written you know in
any scripting language actually you
actually do not use remote plug-in
executors are basically agents that
allow remote script to be executed as
well and these scripts are usually
executed two monitors again your CPU
just initiate number of users logged in
who is logged in those logs at what time
locked out at what time and so all these
monitoring tools work on the concept of
polling so polling is more like you know
they so the NRP agent is a program that
will continuously keep poland a machine
for certain parameters that are
configured in that use to be monitored
so this program continues to keep
pinging the server bringing the program
you know to keep checking for what it
has been asked to check so in case of
logged in users you keep checking at you
know it maybe every 30 seconds or every
one minute
you keep pinging to see how many users
have logged in on to the server and who
are the users who have logged in what
time they logged in what time to log out
and things like that so now just poll
agent on remote machines is what
basically mean I just have the agent
program that can you know help you whole
or things even remote machine
the Nigerian mode data processor is an
agent that allows the inflexible data
transport and you know it uses the HTTP
and
XML protocols to do that and we're
talking about essentially your databases
and data server usage is like you know
couldn't if you have an Oracle database
how many database instances are there
you know how your load balancing is set
up on that how data is moving between
different database servers within Oracle
and how data is moving within the load
balancers and there's always a DI P is
always the back of its database that's
why you see me mentioned TRP as soon as
I say the word database and if there's a
back-up plan you know how hard the data
moving how much time did the backup date
did it take too much time and why you
know why did it take it helps you do all
those kind of monitoring the NS client
is definitely used to monitor Windows
machine and typically when we talk about
servers we end up talking more about you
know UNIX or Linux servers of course now
with a lot of Microsoft technologies
being drawback to that they were you
know like SharePoint or things like that
there are windows level 2 but 10 years
ago if you would talk about having the
Windows Server it's actually kind of
from the power especially for production
and again you know this curfew monitors
usual your CPU your disk usage and it
pulls the plug in in this particular
agent listens to this particular for
always so that rather love port and
usually your system administrators or
server admin administrators know all
these things so a quick overview on
genuis it's a PPR architecture basically
for monitoring system so it has an
instrumentation layer it you know has
all your software agents that are called
Metro fits on all your monitoring system
node once in christen nodes are
basically you know what all objects you
want to monitor you know what all
different kind of object different kind
of servers you want to monitor then it
has an analysis and consolidation layer
you know which basically it deploys all
these metro this agent programs that you
have set on your nose and they goes
basically go and start monitoring what
you want them to monitor by processing
the data they are receiving from servers
from applications from databases from
user activity etc and of course then it
has a visualization layer that if it
leaves a console that lets you view the
status of environment and you know any
current alert it's this kind of
monitoring to usually have a very good
very UI I mean they who do all want to
think in the background but when you
look at the user interfaces there's the
pretty crisp you know there's like say a
place for you to see things that need
your immediate attention they'll use a
lot of color coding you know to indicate
something is Amber's green red etc etc
so this thing also has a console where
you can see the status of different
environment
you know Varian what next both deployed
and what's that stated everything is
fine everything clean if there's a spike
you know when was the spying
what happened did anything crash how did
it stabilize after that
and of course in any alert that are
being thrown on any of these nodes this
is an overview of the architecture these
are basically your the different
controls where yours a visualization
there can have multiple consoles viewing
that you can even have your phone or a
tablet to view that and then this is
your analysis and consolidation there
you know which as your different rules
or whatever what am I wanted to be you
know capturing data for monitoring
computing that and also they have
knowledge base based on what limits you
said what you wanted to monitor with
which off limits
you wanted to monitor and it's you know
does the appropriate database logging
and sends out the appropriate
notifications and then these are your
let floats different nodes where your
next probes are running which are
basically doing the monitoring for like
one two three here he here this box is
the potential server create very clean
easy to understand kind of overview
architecture course we don't need to get
into the details of
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here